[Music]
happy thursday you tapped into the group
chat live in the bleacher report app
presented by fanduel my name is cabbie
richards
her bets have been hitting more than
kevin durant clapbacks on twitter
that is kelly stewart and long before
usher whenever he's in las vegas they
accept bills
with his face on the money because he's
g money
greg ivory it's a true story i've seen
it i've seen it in a pool party
um the community is buzzing over at the
br
app so just search sports betting click
on community i got a salute
brooklyn mambo i tailed you last night
when you wrote
bk bk philly over
that one hit way over so you my friend
are appreciated thank you
every week in our favorite bet our
favorite segment
chuck versus america we bet against the
great charles barkley and we got to give
him his props
because last week he got a rare w
and we took the al america so let's take
a look at the updated standings
we fell to 10 and three that chuckster
is at seven and six we're still
three games ahead but chuck
bet on kawhi leonard to outscore devin
booker in their head-to-head matchup
kelly
did you text charles to tell him to take
kawhi because i don't understand how we
got this one right
no i did not i wish i was cool with
chuck like that i'm like
friend you know when like you're friends
with somebody that's friends with
somebody that's really cool like that
like
that means i would have to like text
other no it'd just be awkward i wish
chuck and i were cool like that though
because then i would have extra fades
you guys know i love to fade my friends
well yeah you do that that is that's
actually accurate that's a fact
you're right well last week you had you
chose kawhi and an american woman devon
booker so we we
sadly took an l but kawhi you know won
the head-to-head matchup
one on his home court more importantly
so let's bring it back to our home court
the three by two
we invented this bet and it's been easy
money so
the question is will there be two
three-pointers made in the first three
minutes of the game
uh tonight we're locking in uh
milwaukee and atlanta but the three by
tuesday's been on fire as well let's
take a look
at the video from earlier this week
portland and
uh boston i want to say i got we have
some thank yous to issue
let's take a look at the video we got to
thank uh damian lillard right from the
jump because when it's game time it's
game time thank you for this
dame that's a three pointer and thank
you christian james on the dho the
dribble handoff
money much appreciated and look that's
in the first 90 seconds of the game the
three by tuesday kemba walker
thank you very much sir you know what
three ain't enough
another one i think maybe maybe we got
to recall this or sorry maybe we've got
to re-brand this one the three by four
because it was so good it hit twice and
uh we probably
got to boost that to plus 200 or plus
220.
so salute to you guys the three by
tuesday tonight
milwaukee and atlanta we posted this
earlier on social will there be two
three-pointers made
in the first three minutes of bucks
versus atlanta let's take a look at the
latest results
75 of you guys on twitter
the twitterverse think that yes it's
gonna happen
those are good vibes g money what kind
of vibes um
uh do we need in the comments today
because uh we took an l last week
america
we do not want to repeat this ouija
money we need good vibes and good vibes
only in the comments cabbie good vibes
and good vibes only
uh you guys let me know if this 3x2 is
gonna hit
i'll give you a uh i'll give you a
pointer which direction to go
just say yes please just say wait hold
on we can't we can't just
last week we lost though we gotta you
gotta pick and choose you're a great
curator we got to pick and choose who we
listen to though g-money
we can't have charles barkley creeping
up on us on the standings my dude cabbie
we'll be all right
i mean based off our track record if
we're betting it yes every time
we will be all right we will be all
right
so you guys let me know if we're riding
a three by two kelly are you riding with
us this week
yes no maybe so greg you've asked me
this for 14 weeks
i think you know the answer let's just
be honest this is free money that's what
i put in the app
but this is even more free money this
week because why
the bucks 28th in the nba and
three-pointers allowed
this team gives up a monster amount of
three-point shots so
i gotta say yes and i wish that they
would let me bet just maybe maybe like a
2x bet this week because that's how much
i like it
i'm leaning the other way you know and
mostly because traders
are cabs trey young is questionable at
this
at this moment so the the the offense
isn't as electric
as when he's he's on the court so um
these are bad vibes cabbie abby and the
world is a great ivory
those aren't that's bad vibes that's bad
vibes underneath that the yeah
yeah there it is babot yeah pop up
please
that's what cabbie just brought
reasonable vibes
look i know that i know the vibes i know
that milwaukee just hit
19 threes against minnesota the other
day so if it's going to happen
in this game it's like bryn forbes or
chris middleton
but i'm leaning no on this this three by
two hey
boston lakers that three by two is gonna
hit but the early one i don't think it's
going to hit
i gave some bad vibes what do you need
in the comments uh
g-money caviar there are other people
that are sharing my vibes
good vibes and good vibes only i see a
lot of yeses in the comments uh
let me let me let me show you guys
something uh for the new people here
this right here is the handy dandy ipad
and this is how you get your hoodies
cabbie kelly i am in the comments uh
motivated motive eight it says bad vibes
cabbie
says you're bringing the bad vibes i see
a lot of bad vibes in the comments i
think i gotta scroll up all right here
we go
jesse bolano says yes he is riding
the three by two shout out to you c
burns allen says they are riding in the
three by two
shout out to uc burns you're walking
away with a hoodie uh
m go blue m go blue says no let's get
back on track i'm
i'm assuming he means yes since he said
let's get back on track
uh yeah shout out to you ben the goat
ben the goat is trolling me in the in
the in the in the in the comments
is he dropping biggest great comments no
no no he's not dropping that bro
has he found one of those dollar bills
with your face on he's saying that i'm
bad at parlay's brother and i'll accept
that i mean if that's what you think
i'll accept it
but guess what you were walking away
with a hoodie for your good lives
with a hoodie yeah it's called reverse
psychology man everybody know i'm about
love man so you you you throw some shade
at me i'm just gonna throw love right
back at you shout out to you ben the
goat
you're walking away with a hoodie hopes
it warms you up this summer
kelly you can you could take a few
things from greg
oh i know i i need to like embrace that
southern charm kathy and just like that
bless your heart
where you don't really mean it but you
say it really nice with a smile i'm
going to work on that
we're also riding with the yes we're
riding with the yes for this three by
two
right so if you guys are riding with us
then
click on br betting socials to get the
link to that boost from
from fanduel guys kyle kuzma dropped
24 on uh on on tuesday night
count it up count it up count it up
count it
we love the race to tenny we need those
we need some sprinters
we need those quick buckets the tenney
is back and tonight it's boston
versus the lakers they say life's not a
a sprint
it's a marathon but we we love this
quick hitter we love the tenney and we
need those dudes to be
jumping out the gates and get some easy
buckets
um g-money what kind of vibes do we want
in the in the in the comments in the
tenney
cabbie uh let's set the vibes man we
need good vibes only a lot of sunsets in
the comments you guys know what to do uh
but
which team will win the race to 10 which
team will win are we going lakers or are
we going
boston are we going to make some fun
bunnies in the comments
bunnies cabbie wants bunnies you guys
drop them things in the comments kelly
are you handicapping this or are you
throwing the dart which
how are you how are you deciding this
one this is a tough handicap
obviously the whole world knows la is
missing their two best players and
anthony davis and lebron
but we got the other half of the team
carl kuzma dennis schroeder everybody's
like
questionable maybe they're probable by
the time the game kicks off
tips off excuse me this is tough
uh i'm on the lakers
regretfully tonight plus six i already
don't feel
real hot about it but we're betting
numbers not teams here plus
this boston team has been on a nice
little stretch here on the road
i think la not only gets the race to 10
but also has a shot to win the game so i
took plus six and
sprinkled a little bit on that money
line boston has been on a nice first
they won six of their last seven
and had two quality wins in the last two
games
at portland at denver so i just i'm
gonna ride this wave
with the celtics and you know they're
you know their
their blood rival is the los angeles
lakers
so why not get it started quick and
early in the staples center
give me the celtics gee money what what
about you where are you leaning into
this one
he's out there i'm laughing at the
comments uh yeah i'm i'm in the comments
man they're all over the place i see a
lot of bunnies cabbie shopping
you and your bunnies man the bunnies are
in the comments easy ones
rich richie 21 says celtics first to 10.
he's rocking with you cabbie uh richie
21 shout out to you you're walking away
with a hoodie
uh mayo five six one says lakers guards
will be on lock with boston in the
beginning
so i guess that means lakers i think so
lakers guards will be on lock with
boston i just shout out to you mayo
you're walking away with a hoodie i
don't know which side you're riding but
just because you're the vibes in the
comment you're walking away with a
rheem dream team tatum since they really
got no one who can stop him
from going off so i'm assuming that ring
dream is rocking with
you cabbie in boston uh
i'm not though cabbie you're not i'm not
yeah
tatum kemba marcus smart jalen brown
they have like their full team and and
everybody's healthy
nah this game's going to be in la right
yeah
it's going to be in la fans are going to
be inside the staples center for this
one what
fans are back it's going to be in la no
braun
no a.d usually they get off to the slow
start you know
they call the time early time out get
things together and come and
you know beat the brakes off of people
how the lakers usually do
this time they're getting off to a fast
start cabbie i'm telling you fans are in
the stands
getting off to a fast start i'm rocking
with the lakers
and kelly's riding bro i'm rocking with
kelly
what is this greg versus cappy today
yeah this is this is weird um guys three
years ago
uh thanos put on the infinity gauntlet
and when he snapped his fingers half of
us
went night night and it felt like that's
happened in the mvp race as well because
in january the front runners
luca kd braun have just
they're out of the pitcher but one that
has remained
one contender that's remained has been
hiding in plain sight
and that's the greek god but with no
oracle to tell us
when he'll return is giannis a good bet
for mvp g-money is there anybody out
there in the comments that has a
giannios mvp ticket cabbie let me ask
them hey
people in the comments let me know who's
winning mvp
this year do you have a honest ticket
are you betting on giannis or do you
have somebody else
uh within the field um kelly
are you do you see value in giannis do
you see value if we sprinkle a little
bit there
i can make a case for giannis at 12 to
one i i really could look they're three
and a half games back we saw the nets
and sixers go head-to-head last night i
do think the sixers will make a push for
that first place
in the east but i also like this bucks
team
to kind of jump ahead there again three
and a half games back this one
seems like it's a possibility giannis at
12-1
is a better bet i think than trying to
bet the bucks to win the east
there's a lot more value there because
if the bucks win the east
guess who's winning mvp i know that it's
really hard to do
uh larry bird's the most recent one that
comes to mind
kareem did it three times three
back to back to back to back mvps is so
hard but sure
i'll make a case for giannis at 12-1 but
i mean he's he's a unicorn actually can
we can we take a look at the current
odds
because the guy that i'm leaning with is
right there at the top that's nicola
jokic he's i'm confident in my nicola
jokic future
in fact i have five futures because i
was just
shooting darts all over the place i have
an embiid future
i have a a brawn future
a steph curry and a kd but i'm confident
in the nikola jokic uh because this
guy's got
15 triple doubles it's basically his mvp
to lose at this point and
unfortunately with the injury to jamal
murray blowing out his acl
he has more of the weight on his
shoulders so he can
so he can show and prove even more that
he's the mvp of that team
and the mvp of the league now as in bean
has come back
and if this dude continues to drop 30
and 10
games uh you know he had a monster
against brooklyn in his last game
then that that gap between jokic and
embiid
will be even even um closer and here's
another
thing if braun returns with
like with 10 games left in the regular
season and puts up a handful of triple
doubles
you know nba writers want to reward
lebron james with his fifth
mvp voted so next week or the week after
we can have this conversation again
and the entire the entire menu will
change
all the odds will change because if
bronze back in the mix
if your guy g money steph curry keeps
playing like it's
friggin nba 2k or if kd like
it's gonna be nuts so it's jokic's
award to lose at this point g-money i
know you're on kevin durant
earlier in the season and since he's
returned he's been efficient
efficiently scoring a ton of buckets
what percentage do you give kevin durant
at this point of the season
to win the mvp if he continues playing
the way he's playing
right now i'll give him a zero cabbie
not even like a two percent chance just
like flat out zero
i'm a realist i'm a realist i'll give
him a zero he hasn't played
enough in order like happy really in my
opinion
in my opinion to quality
he hasn't played enough to qualify for
the mvp this year
but with that being said when that man
is on the court
in the end he is the best nba player
in the league when kevin durant is
healthy and he's and he's playing he's
the best nba
player uh hands down but with that also
being said steph curry should be in this
conversation i don't even know why he's
not on the graphic i don't even know
what people are
talking about it's not even gonna
basically be even in the playoffs
that's fine they might get to be in the
play-in game that's why and that's
unfortunate because i
look stuff is an absolute stun this man
has been putting on a clinic
i agree with you but i just don't see
the voters voting for him that's the
only reason why
yeah i don't see it either but i'm just
saying like the guy's been
bawling go look at the numbers numbers
men lie
women lie numbers don't
right cabbie that's right salute all
right oh here we go
let me get in these comments though let
me get in these comments and see who
they are riding
with and then i'll make my selection uh
i got get money get money gibb says
dame dollar shout out to you get money
gibs you're walking away with a hoodie
ryan ray ryan reyes rocking with you
cabbie
rocking with the joker shout out to you
ryan ray uh ken
g kenji steph is a favorite for me shout
out man me too
kenji steph is a favorite to me shout
out to you uh
you're walking away with it he's not
gonna win mvp though unfortunately
uh they won't vote for him uh i i see a
lot of joker tabby master luke shout out
to you master luke
you're walking away with a hoodie uh
jake so there's no so no one's on
giannis
nobody's like no one believes in the
greek god and no one's got a giannis
ticket in there
jay harold's junior is rocking with the
joker cabbie i absolutely see
no giantesses not one perfect
flying radar 12-1 let's go
not one but yeah but but cabbie
you just smoke on it you spoke on it i
was with kd
when you know when he was healthy before
he got hurt for the hamstring injury
and then i went over to dame lillard
and since i went over to damn willard
i've been rocking with dame little and
that's not gonna change gabby
that's not gonna change it's his value's
too high
he's sitting he's sitting approximately
three and a half games behind the joker
and the nuggets they can't
win big games oh he needs to do he even
beat the celtics the other night
kelly can't they couldn't beat the miami
heat this they can't win big games
kelly i mean they haven't been winning
big games recently i don't
know some things can change things can
change
maybe they go on the win stream you got
about three weeks left
maybe yeah they flip the switch go on a
winch they're just a win
streak away that's what i keep saying
they're a win streak away
a stretch of dame lillard playing like
steph right now averaging like 35.
do that win a couple games he's right
there
plus two two what 2400
plus 2400 yeah it's a little sprinkle
just a little one
it's a little one well hey
uh salute to anybody who's got a honest
ticket salute to anybody who's got a
dame ticket
i mean that is a huge or or steph curry
ticket if if steph curry
can drop 11 three-pointers in the game a
few more times or if dame can
drop some 50 pieces and 60 pieces then
it's gonna be
even more competitive and the tightest
playoff race that
we've seen in like 20 years uh salute to
anybody
that was able to get a nba top shop drop
but the only nft that i'm interested in
the only nft that i want in my life
is the one where g money is celebrating
hitting a five-leg
same game partly what would that look
like g-money if you actually
hit one of these fifty five to one
actually
that actually paid what do you mean we
just hit one like
less than a month ago there was so much
there was that was controversial
like it that wasn't a real one that paid
for real kathy what do you mean we went
we went we went before the jury the
people
voted no no no actually like i actually
paid you
real american dollars not even money or
minus 140. like i'm talking like a real
five teamer
that pays 25 to one or better like what
would you actually do i want to see you
go ham like
oh so look so look
i won the bet with you i won the parlay
that week
and i went ham i went to vegas so that's
what i would do when i win a five-team
parlay
i go to vegas
i i i go to vegas i am all right kelly
any any
anyway what are we here for should we
pull up the graphic like okay so wait
last week last week you hit us with the
ds special
it's dennis schroeder and uh this is a
lot of greens
he didn't make one three this is the
best part minus 580
did intruder to make one three didn't
hit well well well hold on kelly minus
320 to score 15 plus points didn't hold
on
hold on kelly he ended the game with 12.
early on early on in the game we were
riding the three by two we were watching
this live we were on the live instagram
live
he shot a three he made it
that's right yeah andre drummond
came and go tinted the basket therefore
it did not count
now if that would have counted we would
have hit the three by two
as well as that parlay that was just
pulled up would have
hit but it's okay and it's okay it is
it's okay you know what's cool about
that
is that that fanduel refunded the three
by two
because of the gold tending because we
would
shout out to fanduel for making greg
actually have to abide by
you know the box fort hey shout out to
fanduel shout out to fanduel because
that was plugged they they did come up
clutch
refunding everybody their money shouts
out to them uh
you guys ready to get into this one or
whatever yeah so you're back at it do
you have another
do you have another special for today's
uh today same game parley you got
the milwaukee bucks and the atlanta
hawks tabby
we're going to call this the double b
special and i'll tell you guys why in a
minute we're going to call this the
double b
special though here we go we're going to
get right into it we're going uh
we're going to go with the bucks first
half bucks first half
let's do the money line let's not just
spray let's do some of the money let's
put something on the [ __ ]
money line put the money on 150 of
course i just
it's just so easy we're trying to get
wins here kelly we're
we're just trying to get wins we're just
trying to see the ball go through the
through the basket
again because we already saw it and then
you paid me for the first time but we're
just trying to see it again
here we go moving on we're going to go
we're going to take the over on this
game we're going to take the over
sitting at 2 30 and a half we're going
to go over
this game got that one from you kelly i
like that
actually i'll give you the reason why my
good friend ralph tweeted this this
morning
hawks 17-1 to the over when they're
a home dog which they're plus four and
whenever the total is over
221 so i'm with you on that over greg i
like that as well
okay solid guys trey young is
questionable
and there's no yana santa tecumpo in
this game he's out so like how are we
getting
to 231 points in this game wait that's
exactly how we're gonna get there who's
gonna play defense
kelly that's a great point but cabbie i
have somebody somebody that's
i'm gonna talk about next who's gonna
help this okay here we go bogdan
bogdanovic okay pull it up guys pull it
up pull it up he's a scorer
he's a scorer over 17 and a half points
my guy's going to be putting the ball
in the net all game cabbie he's going to
be putting the ball in the net so much
the other facets of his game is going to
take a dip it's going to take a dip
kelly you're going to be happy you're
going to be happy with me
fanduel now is accepting over and unders
on bets for the same game parlay so
we're going to go with
under we're going to go with under i'm
floored
three and a half assists under three and
a half assists so he's just he's just
getting me straight up scoring he's not
he's not looking to pass at all you just
need that dude to be a good not look in
the past too
not looking to pass putting the ball in
the net and not only are we going with
under three and a half assists we're
also going to take the under in rebounds
we're going to go under four and a half
kelly i hope this one makes you happy i
really do this is this is pretty good
because like yeah and now that it's
going to be even money
let me see let's see the ticket that's
what i wanted that's what i thought even
harder yeah what is
actually yeah on this one plus 1800 okay
seven this one's legit one oh this one's
legit goodness
i'm floored before you know i think the
the only one that could be tricky g
money is the bucks
first half money line because atlanta's
been cooking under interim head coach
i like atlanta a lot tonight uh nate
mcmillan
is 16 and five or 17 and five since
march the first so but there's no trey
young so
yeah you might this one might hit and
the kelly's it's baking in the cake
is this one certified like does this one
meet your expectation for
this get in the kelly approval five leg
part it doesn't it's still not 22
but at least it's not even money
all right all right okay well listen
remember what you learned today some
people will never be satisfied
uh when you come to las vegas
you can spend money with greg ivory's
face on you got to go to dre's to get
those bucks but they're they're here
so forget ursher we got g running actual
g money
and hammered that three by two tonight
we're locking in the milwaukee bucks and
the atlanta
atlanta hawks thank you so much for
tapping into the group chat here on
bleach report presented by fanduel
alongside kelly stewart and greg ivory
my name is cabbie richards and we are
leaving peace
[Music]
[Music]
you